thanks yeah I want to go through factor
analysis and continue our tour of em
because it puts us in this position
where we are going to have uh to make
some pretty serious modeling assumptions
to make progress and it's going to kind
of force us to walk through uh what that
looks like in an unsupervised way so
that's what the factor analysis piece is
we will then cover a little bit of PCA
which is an old standby and it's good to
contrast these two kind of methods
together it's kind of the old more uh
you know less Bayesian less
probabilistic uh standby that people use
a lot in unsupervised learning
just to give you a sense of where we are
in the course
um the uh up next for us will be this
problem called ICA which would be great
that's going to be in your homework it's
always one of people's favorite homework
problems this is the cocktail party
problem which we'll go through and if we
have time I'm not sure we will but if we
have time on our current trajectory
we'll go through something called weak
supervision which is a which is a setup
that looks just like em uh this
expectation maximization setting except
for we can solve the underlying problem
exactly so some folks were asking
questions last time hey why don't I run
method X Y or Z on this and there are
these latent problems where actually you
can cut to the Chase and exactly solve
the the to the right answer you don't
have to run this kind of back and forth
style algorithm and so we'll see that if
we have time and kind of give you a
sense of of why that's interesting this
is more modern stuff
um that we'll we'll talk about all right
now on to factor analysis this is what
we're going to talk about and this is a
setting where we have more Dimensions
than we have day data points now just by
way of history when we used to give
these lectures about factor analysis it
seemed like kind of an odd situation why
would you have so many more Dimensions
that you that you cared about in your
model then you have data points but
actually weirdly like if anything in the
last couple of years modern machine
learning has switched to that being
almost the default we tend to train much
much larger models as you saw than we
have available data and there's a couple
of reasons for that they're not the
reasons that are in factor analysis just
to be clear but this setting is actually
a pretty interesting one and so we'll
see how people addressed it initially
awesome so let's talk about factor
analysis
factor analysis
right so we have many fewer points
data points
then dimensions
that's the setting that we're in okay
and kind of first notation this is n is
much less than d
okay
so it's worth comparing this by the way
with gmms
in gmms if you remember we had only a
couple of parameters right we had the
source centers we had the source
variances we had the free and we had the
kind of fraction that were in each
Source but we assumed implicitly we had
a ton of photons if you remember from
all of the different uh things that were
going on from all the different sources
and so n was much much greater than D
okay and that was kind of implicit in
what we were doing but it's worth
calling out and the reason is is we
would we would average over some sources
and we didn't have to worry
about a couple of problems which we'll
highlight in this lecture okay
all right so let me give you an example
of how this happens because you know at
first you may look at that and say like
well is that really kind of realistic
and even though I tell you it's kind of
become the default setting it's good to
have something kind of concretely in
mind so what's one way that this happens
so one example which is you know
actually stanford-based is that we could
place sensors all over campus
okay all over campus
and let's say Those sensors read tons of
information temperatures and wind speed
all kinds of things and so they record
at thousands of locations at thousands
of locations
locations
and values okay so just a huge amount of
information but so D is you know in the
thousands or tens of thousands or tens
of thousands
okay so these are like little smart dust
sensors everywhere okay but they only
record for 30 days
but only
for 30 days
okay so we get like you know n here is
we get 30 samples now the sample we get
if you like is a measurement across the
entire area of Campus so it's like we're
getting a matrix that's kind of in the
opposite direction from what we're used
to it's skinny but it's not tall and
skinny it's n rows and then the rows are
really really big okay
all right
so I would just point out maybe it's not
obvious why it will be obvious hopefully
in a second that we would want to fit a
density to this
but it kind of seems hopeless and the
reason it seems hopeless is we've had
every model that we've had had a
parameter for every dimension
and so now there's a huge number
intuitively a huge number of models that
are out there that will all kind of
satisfy this data if we were to run
something like least squares right if
you only gave me five examples and you
had a thousand uh Dimensions there are
tons of models that line up on those
five points right that kind of touch
that rank five Subspace
but all the rest of them are free so how
do we pick from it and if we try to do a
probabilistic thing it gets even worse
okay
so let's let's see the key idea and if
it's not obvious to you that's a it's a
problem we'll show you something very
Concrete in a moment that it's a problem
so this is mainly intuition right now
this is not mathematically grounded
we'll show you the math in a second and
what will happen is you'll see our
equations will just break in some
fundamental way
and so our key idea to get out of this
is that we're going to assume
there is some latent structure because
that's the tool we're using right now
random variable
that is not too complex
and not too complex means that I can
estimate it that's really what it means
operationally
and
captures most of the behavior captures
the interesting Behavior right and this
is the tired Maxim in this course
that you know all models are wrong some
models are useful right it's not going
to be a perfect model of what's going on
but it captures most of the interesting
behavior in this relatively compact way
and so we'll see at the end of this
little section we'll see a concrete
generative model that that builds with
these building blocks and allows us to
recover those parameters
that's the key idea
okay so let's see the first problem with
why gmms would have challenges here and
see the first first example and actually
we're going to look at something even
simpler than gmms we're going to look at
fitting a single gaussian okay so let's
try and fit a single gaussian in this
situation so I can make more concrete my
assertion before like it's hard to fit
models here so let's fit one gaussian
okay so the gaussian has two parameters
recall there's mu and sigma Square
so how would we be tempted to compute
them so first we want to compute the
mean of our data well that actually
seems to kind of make sense we compute
the sum here
oops
some over all of our data one to n right
so just make sure let me write the data
because I should have written it up we
have data points RN element of Rd just
to make sure those
types are in your head
okay
this is okay this works fine
we compute the mean that seems fine it
doesn't matter how high the dimensions
are right you can compute the mean and
it's a sensible Sensible thing to do
right may not be a great estimate of the
center right because you may not have
all combinations of the directions but
it's it's still an okay enough estimate
the trouble comes when we look at the
covariance and I'm going to right here
the covariance in the full general form
because we need to talk about the
dimension
because the dimension is high so I can't
just use the one Sigma
and if you remember you have some
expression which roughly looks like this
x i minus mu
t
okay so that's a fair enough quantity
you can form that quantity
but one thing cause it should cause us a
little bit of pause
what's the rank of Sigma
well generally we've been assuming when
we did linear regression and everything
else the rank was at least D the number
of Dimensions like it was a full rank
object right but the problem here is
that D is much bigger than n
and I've just shown you that Sigma can
be written
as a sum
of n rank one vectors and if you
remember your linear algebra that means
that the rank here is less than which is
always true the minimum of N and D which
in this case
is going to be strictly less than d
because if n is smaller than D that's
what we're assuming okay so this is in
full rank so where does that cause us a
problem well we have to go back and
write our favorite function the gaussian
likelihood and see where this causes a
problem
likelihood
okay
so remember our favorite thing look like
this
Sigma
is equal to at 1 over 2 pi
Sigma one-half
X
Pi minus
transpose Sigma inverse x i oh there
should be no x i sorry should just be X
get through this
at the bottom of it
and so on
okay awesome
why is this formula problematic if Sigma
doesn't have full rank well there's two
parts that kind of don't make sense
right
one of them is this
if it's not full rank the inverse
doesn't make sense right it's not even
defined
and second
this is the determinant what's the
determinant
zero now you're toast because it's one
over zero this is now Infinity
or something like it or undefined no
matter what it's going to cause you a
problem if you start to normalize by
something like this
okay so how are we going to fix this
right so this by the way just to make
sure that's clear this determinant is
equal to zero
okay now we're going to fix these issues
just one second we're going to fix these
issues by changing the model and that
model is going to come out and the thing
that I want you to think about is we're
going to try and make that covariance
full rank okay and we're going to see
various assumptions that we can place on
the underlying noise model
this will make sense in a minute that
allow us to insist that Sigma in fact is
full rank you had a question yeah
oh because the German is a product of
the eigenvalues and at least some number
of them are zero
right
awesome
okay so the way we're going to fix this
is we're going to examine these simple
models now the reason you know I'm going
to put these models pedagogically and
why I'm doing it in this order is the
final model is going to take these
building blocks and put them together
okay so you know if you were like really
into the suspense of what's going on
with our sigmas here like I've ruined it
for you that's what's going to happen in
about 20 minutes but what I'm going to
show you are different ways that we can
get around this challenge so that we can
estimate the covariance
get a gaussian likelihood for that
setting and they're all going to boil
down to ways that we kind of make sure
that our covariance is parameterized by
something fewer than all of the roughly
N squared parameters covariance has to
be positive 7A definite so but it still
has a lot of parameters okay so it's not
all full not every Matrix is a
covariance matrix
but a lot of them are
all right so let's go through it
now
let me just recall the mle for gaussians
because it will make our
uh life a little bit easier here called
oops
the reason I'm recalling this is we're
just going to I want to store some facts
or remind you of some facts that will be
useful now one thing just so you're
clear like on on using this these are
just helpful things to know about
um like kind of computing these em
models again and again so hopefully this
is useful practice even if you're not
Computing these so remember we the way
we fit these things to data looks like
this we sum over all of the data we take
the log
of 1 over 2 times the likelihood uh
X
of
oh sorry there's a negative one-half
here that doesn't change the story one
half
x minus mu transpose Sigma inverse x
minus mu
and so on okay
now the this is equivalent to minimizing
the log which we which we kind of do
everywhere and expand out which is
equivalent to minimizing this and you've
seen this before I just want to remind
you where it comes from
some I equals 1 to n
x minus mu transpose Sigma inverse this
is why I consistently drop the one-half
because it doesn't matter but it is
distracting okay
all right now one key fact which we will
use again and again and I'm just going
to dispense of once
is if Sigma is full rank
the covariance is full rank
then Sigma U of this function here
so I'll just call
uh
F of mu or f i of mu is equal to the sum
I equals one let me extend the purple
blob pink blob one to n
Sigma inverse x i minus U implies
mu equals 1 by n some I equals 1n so I
apologize if this is too pedantic if not
what I'm saying here is this is a
plug-in if we know no matter what that
Sigma is full rank then I can use this
estimate from mu okay so I was saying
before that the average was no problem
so long as Sigma is of the right form I
can always do this and remember why if
this is full rank I can pull it out this
is the same argument we went through
last time so ask me a question if it's
not clear because you have seen this
before
and so then we satisfy from you we can
just use that as a plug-in for
everything we do later sure
so if it's not for rank so let's imagine
that it had some null space then it
could be then then this x minus mu could
be satisfied by either being identically
zero which would be in the null space no
matter what or anything that's collinear
with the null space that has like a so
if the null space is you know a
particular direction then it doesn't
Define mu it can be anything along that
direction will be set to Zero by this
right so it means the mean wouldn't be
the unique minimizer of it right
cool
that would be zero plus nothing go ahead
oh like
just highlight that find any information
that's exactly right and the summation
it was just so I didn't have to copy it
again
yeah this is just exactly this and this
is yeah this is the exact calculation
we've seen a couple times
this is after heavy competition of the
first line that we have done earlier
yeah so this is basically saying these
two are equivalent right well we saw
this before that if we wanted to
maximize likelihood it was equivalent to
minimizing this loss functional I want
to use that because I want to this this
is a lot simpler and it doesn't have
like all kinds of like extraneous terms
and things that I need to to deal with
and so I want to get to the point where
I can just operate on this so that I can
give you some mathematical facts when I
draw the pictures
that's why that's why I'm doing it
you could do everything in terms of the
original equation there's no
harm or foul from doing that and you
know yeah
you may prefer to do it that way
cool
and we're using the fact that like the
constants don't matter and all the usual
stuff
when we go to minimizing
okay so let's see our first building
block
there's a picture coming I don't know
why I think this will not pique your
interest but I'm still going to tell you
there's a picture coming that I think is
very fun to draw that uses all the
building blocks together and I'll
highlight for you when we get there it's
a it's a real privilege to draw this
ridiculous picture for you and it's
going to be really disappointing after
the setup so I'm very excited for it
that's like maximizes my enjoyment okay
so here I want to think about the first
building block that we're going to draw
this is not a fun picture to draw but
it's it's okay so suppose
that we assume that every direction
makes has independent and identical
independent
and identical
correlation or covariance
okay so if I think about the noise ball
what does it look like I'll draw 2D here
oops come on Snap two
so what this means is that our model of
kind of gaussian noise if you think
about it so this will be Sigma is equal
to Sigma squared I okay so that means
it's it's I and the only free parameter
is this Sigma squared which is a scalar
this is a scalar
okay so how many free parameters are
there precisely one right the structure
is the covariance is Sigma squared times
I so what does that actually look like
it looks like I have a point which can
be centered anywhere the gaussians can
be centered anywhere they can have
arbitrary means but their covariance
structure looks like circles
one Circle
second Circle they should be concentric
the limitations of my
notability skills okay
there could be another one down here
okay they all have the same
okay
so you may look at this and say so this
is like the pictures these covariances
are circles
but I'm just trying to emphasize what
this restriction means and so that
circle is just parameterized by two
point by two
numbers you know vectors the center the
MU
and then its radius
okay and that's what Sigma squared is
so in this situation
what is the mle
what is the X well we know mu because
this is full rank why is this full rank
because it's scalar times the identity
as long as Sigma squared is bigger than
zero this is a uh this is a full rank
Matrix right
rank is exactly n
so what is the mle
well we're minimizing now over one free
parameter
and
it looks something like this
one to n
x i
minus mu
except for when we take the transpose
here it's all times a scalar so I'll
pull the scalar out in front and it'll
be minus Sigma squared
okay plus d
log Sigma squared right so the
determinant of this thing is the
dimension times Sigma squared well it's
the determinant of this thing is Sigma
to the 2D and the log of that is D Times
log Sigma squared
okay determine as a product of the
eigenvalues all the eigenvalues are
Sigma squared how many eigenvalues are
there d
so I'm just saying in a very complicated
unnecessarily complicated way
this is true then I'm just taking a log
and writing it in that form
okay
so just for notational purposes let Z
equal Sigma squared
what does this actually look like well
it's minimizing 1 over Z
times this thing is a constant here
this does not depend on Sigma squared
anyway so I'm just going to call this c
c
Plus
D log Z
Min Z
so just take the derivative
what do I get
minus Z over 2 C plus d over Z
equals zero
and if I've done my job correctly this
is going to be Z is equal to C over ND
I.E Sigma squared equals c over ND
okay just to write it to make sure it's
just to unpack it so you understand so
you don't get lost in the weird
notational pieces this is basically what
I'm saying this is the estimate
okay
I minus yeah okay hopefully this makes
sense what is it saying it's saying
average over all of the different
variances that are there treat them as
if they're basically ND of these things
that are estimates that you're seeing
Sigma ND times
average over them
and that's what you should get so
another way to describe the rule here is
subtract the mean and square all the
entries
abstract mean
and square
roughly okay
so what do you know at this point
oh please
aren't we missing a sum overnight and
from the defeat
um oh sorry so yes these are part of the
two things so when this comes out this
should have an ND here sorry yeah this
my simplification on the fly to simplify
my notes did not make sense that's a
great catch this thing is going to be C
and this sum is inside each of the ends
and so this should be ND sorry about
that wonderful catch
awesome
please
yeah so the the idea here is we have
some direction and so one intuitive way
to think about this is there's some
radius that makes sense and you know how
to fit a radius on any Dimension right
so you know exactly how to do this if it
were one dimensional and what this is
basically saying is I Collapse all the
variance and all directions and it's
almost like I just lay them out in a
line and average across all of them and
what I'm saying is that's not too
surprising this math is the correct way
to understand what should happen that
intuition is not going to help you too
much but at least lets you type check
that like it makes sense and it has the
right Dimension and what's great there
as was pointed out was this ND is just
averaging over all the entries right
like and the N has to come from from
averaging over the other interests
so Sigma squared is a scalar so it's
just going to be a single number but
then we're going to multiply it times
the identity so if you picture it it's
just going to be that number repeated on
the diagonal
please
took them back with four wheelers and
this is actually the same like
entertainment right so yeah so and any
model is always going to be a
hypothetical situation we're always
talking about what are we modeling here
and so what we're modeling here is let's
imagine a situation where this would be
appropriate it'd clearly be perfect in
the case where we had noise that we knew
was it was actually the same magnitude
in absolutely every direction and didn't
depend on the underlying data we'll talk
about procedures that try and make us
close to that in the later part of the
lecture but ignore that for one minute
that will probably never be true
empirically right for a variety of
reasons but this is a pretty good
approximation if they don't fluctuate
too much do you want to pay the
expressive power of having to model all
the different fluctuations and all the
different possible ways all the
different ellipses that you could
possibly have and this is saying like if
no if they're kind of if they they have
the even distribution then this is an
OKAY model
let's see a slightly uh let's see our
second building block they're not lots
of building blocks there are two okay
let's see our second building block
all right building block two
so Sigma is going to look like this
it's going to be diagonal
d
Square
now what does this look like in my head
these are access aligned ellipses what
do I mean
well
they may differ
like this
that's pretty good
all right
so these these this noise parameter is
still parameterized by a mean which we
know how to set this is clearly full
rank why is this clearly full rank well
because all the numbers are greater than
zero its eigenvalues are all positive so
it's full rank it's clearly it's also by
the way clearly a p is clearly a
positive semi-definite or positive
definite because all those numbers are
positive okay so it is a covariance
matrix
and this is what it looks like it's
basically saying that it does the
ellipses the errors are not correlated
across multiple Dimensions they're
basically independent on each of the
dimension and so the error profile is
going to look
like a flat ellipse
all right
so this is basically saying I have
Dimensions that differ wildly but I
don't care about how often they interact
right that's roughly the model that you
have in your head right like there's a
lot more variance in component one than
component two that's worth modeling to
me but not at all how they interact okay
right
so we're going to set zi equal to Sigma
I squared
as above same thing we did above
we're going to minimize now over Z1 to
ZD
these are all scalar values all positive
two doesn't matter too much
sum J
d
oh J equals one and I erase that
one to D
minus 1 J times x i minus mu
J squared this is now a scalar plus log
z i okay and this is inside the
parentheses are inside this thing let's
write it just because it's the way it
should associate
okay oh that should be J
see if I made any other books probably
we'll get there
all right so far so good what does this
look like
well the reason I wrote it out like this
so first be clear about what we did here
this broke out per dimension
so really
this is just D independent problems
right so what should we expect
we can go ahead and compute this thing
but it's going to look like
a problem we've solved many times before
okay sorry this is J that's the typo
there
J Square
plus log Z J which implies
Sigma J square equals 1 over n
sum J equals 1 to n
sorry
J is the dimension I equals one
x i minus mu I Square let me make sure I
have well mu
J muj all right let me write that again
so that it's clear since there were a
bunch of typos there
some I goes from 1 to n
x i j
minus mu J Square okay so what's going
on here
the thing that's going on here is we
have D independent problems
that means we have D1 dimensional
problems and this is exactly the
estimate that we had for one dimensional
covariance
there's really nothing else going on
there are a couple of bits here that
we're using the jth mean and the jth
component it's like every component was
handled independently
all right we are ready to talk about our
Factor model
okay so what is this what is the purpose
of me going through all this one is I
want you to get very I want you to be
pretty comfortable with kind of going
back and forth between hey what is my
mle what does the structure I put in and
how does that change my estimate okay
that actually is pretty interesting you
put in the different structure it
reduces the number of free parameters
and that allows you to estimate things
with far fewer amounts of data
we're going to combine that now in a
pretty interesting way which is what the
factor model actually is
our Factor model
okay another reason to give this is an
example of a more sophisticated
generative model than we've typically
been used to yeah
sure sure
so because so in general a covariance
matrix is an ellipse you can picture
that ellipse right where the different
directions correspond to the eigenvalues
right
and so what's going on here is that
instead because we're putting it on a as
a kind of a on the diagonal that means
that the stretch is only on the on the
individual axis so like you have
something that's access aligned like the
major axises have to be aligned so when
would that be a reasonable model it'd be
a reasonable model if you thought like
there are different amounts of spread or
different amounts of variance for every
Dimension right the previous model said
all the variants in any direction was
effectively the same there was one
parameter so that's why it was a circle
now it says there's different amounts in
different directions but I'm not going
to model their interaction in contrast
to General covariance Matrix can tilt
and say like no the principal Direction
which will come to you when we talk
about PCA okay is in One Direction and
I'm a little bit setting up for those
kind of calculations later is why I draw
these right so this this says I don't
care about interactions between the
features rough very roughly speaking
basically it's saying that there's that
each Direction no no they're different
there's a different parameter for
everything so there's Sigma 1 and sigma
2 are potentially different numbers
right that's why it's that's why it's an
ellipse rather than a circle they're all
the same it would be the circle cool
awesome
fantastic so let's look at our
parameters there are going to be a lot
of them
but it gives us a more interesting
generative model to look at and if you
kind of Wade your way through this
you understand em you understand how
these models work and hopefully it gives
you confidence that you're not looking
at just one
setting okay r d by D
it's going to be a diagonal matrix
okay
all right so let's see the model and
then the world's I don't know it's not
really that remarkable picture but I
enjoy it
all right PX of Z
so we do the usual thing here that it
factors as a latent model this is
exactly the same since Z is our as our
latent model
okay by the way mu is an RD this is a
linear transformation that we're going
to learn this is a diagonal
transformation harkening back to what we
just talked about
and here is the way X is distributed X
or sorry Z
start with z
is going to be sum 0 1
so it's just some random noise Vector in
RS
for some s smaller than d
okay this is this I'm going to call this
s because I wanted you to think about it
as the small dimension
so the latent structure is small we want
to pick the latent structure to be much
smaller D is thousand ten thousand a
million a billion something like this
we're going to pick s is saying there's
a small Subspace that characterizes and
classifies all of its Behavior that's
like the compression that's the
bottleneck
then we're going to say x and I'll walk
through this slowly in a second
is this expression
Epsilon okay
all right so the model that generates X
and I'll write this more compactly X is
not just centered at the origin it has
some mean
Z is going to be mapped from the small
Dimension to the large Dimension by a
transformation that we're going to learn
so imagine the sampling procedure is Z
gets selected if you knew Lambda you
would map it up into Rd
you'll shift it by Epsilon by mu the the
mean that you're going to learn and then
you're going to put some Epsilon noise
here
okay
all right now
let's get the model for these things so
Epsilon oops Epsilon is going to be
normal
it's noise so it'll have zero mean
and it will have
Phi as its parameters
this implies by the way now we have all
the information we could also write X is
distributed
as n mu plus Lambda Z
plus Phi
please
yeah great question so let me just say
so this is I just want to annotate this
is the mean
so I'm going to draw
what goes on on this for an example in
one second that will answer this a
little bit better than I'm able to
because once you see what's going on but
the intuition is you're going to sample
in the small space
you don't know where it is that's your
latent variable that's your link to
clusters that's the thing that you say
like I don't know what it is but I know
there's a small structure lurking out
there then Lambda says from that small
space I'm going to go into the big space
right the D the D much higher
dimensional space and Lambda I'm going
to learn that transformation that says
how do I go from the small space to the
big space and then the big space is
going to be the actual dimensions so
imagine I was con I was actually had
these sensors and they were getting
temperature readings all over campus and
they were getting wind readings all over
campus well clearly they're correlated
right like if I put a bunch of sensors
all in a line they're not independent
readings right there's some sensor and
then there's some map that tells me from
the reading I got what should I expect
at all the sensors with like pretty high
probability like you could imagine such
a map existing and so the Lambda is that
map that goes from the kind of low
Dimension to the high dimension we're
just doing it in a very abstract way and
we're not specifying what those
Dimensions even mean to start with right
please
uh you probably don't want to set it
greater than n for a variety of reasons
but like yeah
like you'll see in a second what the
conditions are when you go to solve it
great great question there's some
condition that's lurking there you need
to be able to estimate there are no free
lunch right but yeah you it's going to
be smaller than d right d is a billion
and N is 20. there exists some s where
we could potentially solve this that's
the way to think about it not we can
solve it for every yes
awesome
right so let's see an example
of this whole thing where D is equal to
so not that high dimension but like good
for drawing s is equal to one
and N is equal to five okay and our
model is X mu plus Lambda Z Plus Epsilon
and let's see how the forward sampling
works so how does it work one
we generate
Z1
to ZN
from
n01 so what does this look like
all right
so here's here's zero and we get let me
see if I can
draw this nicely we get a bunch of
samples so maybe here's zero let me mark
down zero
zero
oh that doesn't look right
zero so here's the let me draw the
density actually so the density looks
like something like this right this is
the gaussian and you know Loosely
interpreted artist rendition of
gaussians
then what I'll do is I'll sample so
maybe I'll sample this point first
and I sample over here
sample here sample here simple here
those are my Five Points how did I pick
them I don't know I sampled so like this
is z oops
this is the
one this is Z2 I'm not remembering the
order that I did it and it doesn't
really matter
C3 Z5 Z4
okay so I just generated those in one
dimensions
right now two what happens so now so far
I've generated I've done this piece
all right so this character
is handling this
okay now
I map by Lambda so let's suppose
we've already learned Lambda
so Lambda is equal to one two
so what happens next
now we're getting fancy
take this copy
paste
so now
we need the x-axis back
so these things get mapped here's the
line
one two which goes to the origin
okay what happens
so then
these are all mapped onto the line
oops so small but good enough this one's
mapped all the way up here okay
down here
and down here
okay
so this point for example is
um
[Music]
this point is Lambda Z3
this point is Lambda Z2
so far so good
so this whole thing
now we're in dimension we're in the high
dimension so we've gone from our small
Dimension up to the whole dimension of
all our sensors think in your head
Dimension ten thousand not Dimension two
okay
now
three
we add mu
what does that do I'll put that in green
that's this piece
copy
paste
mu let's say is this dirt is this Vector
here
this is Mu
we add mu to everything
and that translates
all our points now
by mu
and there's one off the screen now over
here
okay
this point
is oops
mu plus Lambda Z 2. right
it's this point translated by mu
then four
we add Epsilon noise
and this Epsilon noise is full
dimensional
so I'm going to make this in purple
just character here
right this is the equation that we're
dealing with
what happens next we get some purple
stuff and it goes like this oops make it
a little bit thicker goes like this
goes down here goes over there but it's
full dimensional noise it lives in a d
dimensional space
and that is our final expression so for
example
this character here
oops
this character here is Mu plus Lambda Z
2 plus Epsilon 2. and Epsilon 2 is the
noise and notice the noise is in
different direction for each one
right so I want this this is in by the
way this is in the high dimensional
space and dimension d
okay so what's going on here
we were talking about that sensor and
temperature example so just kind of walk
through the Z's here were generated in
one dimension let's say that was the
underlying true temperature that you
were going to see several samples of it
maybe at different times of the day
right because Z was collected at various
different times for different data
points right we were collecting it many
times in the day then we mapped using
Lambda to say like oh if the temperature
were kind of the the true temperature or
some hidden temperature was you know 50
degrees then all of the other
temperatures that are nearby are going
to jiggle in a predictable amount
predictable amount meaning Lambda Maps
them from wherever their value was to
the high dimensional space right
but the problem is there's still some
residual noise that fit may not be
perfect right we can't predict things
noise means like just stuff we don't
want to model and that's where this
purple comes in that's the Epsilon
Jitter that's in in the high dimension
does that make sense and that's that's
our underlying model
and the data we see
are the purple dots
so the data are the purple dots that's
what we actually see in our the data are
the purple dots
just to make sure
x equals mu plus Lambda Z Plus Epsilon
all right please oh this is
so even though the census gives us uh
dimensional Dimension D which is really
huge but are we assuming that the actual
thing that we won't model like
that's exactly right so much smaller
than D so what we're assuming is we have
again I think the illustrative example
which will get you most of the way there
is I put a thousand temperature sensors
in a row so I get a thousand numbers
every time I measure them but if they're
all close enough it feels like there
should be one temperature and they're
all kind of you know there's a mapping
from them that mapping we're going to
learn that's what Lambda is Lambda takes
us from that one true temperature to our
guess at all the different temperatures
but we're aware that that's imperfect
and since we're aware that that's
imperfect we also allow ourselves some
error Epsilon in each one maybe one
temperature sensor is damaged it's dirty
someone walk by it someone blew on it
who knows
that's what Epsilon models does that
make sense and so it's a small to big
like it's like and that's what allows us
to learn this because we're saying
although there's a huge amount of free
parameters we only have a little amount
of data
we have to make some compression and so
that's what the latent structure is
doing
okay please
first is that you know it's actually
really good because you win the meters
this is something close to
um it's linearly it's a linear power
data just having a bit of noise in it
yeah so here we're making an assumption
that's right we're making an assumption
that there is a small distribution
there's a there's a distribution uh
that's that's low and if there's a
linear map up into the larger space you
could imagine more sophisticated models
that had a learnable non-linear map into
the larger space
um and there are various regions that
may be hard and limited data regimes you
may not have enough data to learn that
piece
regression products to S so here s is
equals to one right
yeah wonderful question and we'll get
into this a little bit in PCA too and
sometimes they're interpretable
sometimes they're not but let's imagine
when we come back to it we'll have this
language of principal components in
about 15 minutes that will maybe able to
give a little bit more precise answer so
I may punt there in a second the idea is
that s captures kind of the important
directions of variation so like if you
imagine the temperature sensor so I have
temperature and I have electrical
current that are there and maybe there's
also some you know uh wind thing and if
I combined all three of those I would
get a really good estimate but I need an
estimate of like the wind speed at a
location and all the rest then s would
be some mixture potentially of those
kind of you know true directions that
are out there now often that story that
we tell ourselves is difficult to verify
because we don't actually get to see the
latent variable and in fact we can get
away with making a much weaker
assumption which we'll make in PCA which
is basically that there exists some low
dimensional space that captures our
system and that turns out to be a fairly
robust kinds of assumptions it's not
that we know there are only these three
parameters if we knew it was wind and
temperature and we were just learning
the map we would just feed that in right
we would just measure that and feed that
in we're hypothesizing that there exists
this small bottleneck and that's what's
going to allow us to learn in this
setting and to me that's the really rich
pedagogical reason to teach this is like
like it kind of forces you to think
about like what can you really recover
this is more of a statistics view of
this part of machine learning but what
can you really recover from data right
[Music]
yeah you're just saying this is there
exists something small
oh
um
do you create this transformation for
every data point wonderful question so
here Lambda is across all the different
data points this transformation so so if
you look at like this notation here like
you'll see that Z is generated once uh
per data point so there are n of those
things n latent samples they're also n
noise samples those are different for
every data point that are there but
Lambda is shared across all of them as
Is mu and the model now if you knew
something like you knew there were K
clusters and there were K different Maps
you could potentially fold that into
your model or k different means but this
is the model we're looking at now
doesn't necessarily need to be that way
but for now that's what we're looking at
um
great question I I get exactly what
you're saying so when we went up here
remember in this model so one of the
messages is we start with this model and
in a generative way of viewing things
like the the real reason I like to keep
this in the in the class in a very
fundamental way is because like it
forces you to think about what is
actually in the model like when you see
the EM thing it's kind of in a similar
situation where you're like oh there's
just this one kind of hidden aspect to
it this Z is latent to us so the part of
the model is you pick s because it's one
of the parameters so you have to tell me
ahead of time I want you to model with
you know a size s model and then you run
this whole thing forward and then our
goal is among all those things that
could have gone forward what are the
most likely settings of the parameters
in that model so we're not learning s in
some sense we'll talk about in PCA when
we're learning a linear Subspace we can
effectively look at a particular measure
and see if it's a if you know adding one
more Dimension would be there and it'll
come with some caveats great great
questions
awesome
all right
okay so we need one technical tool to
make this whole thing go let's do some
technical tools
I'm not sure that these are super useful
to prove here
but I will happily Point them out to you
um as we use them all right so here
we're going to use this notation
you probably have seen this before if
not don't worry we'll review it right
now X1 is an R D1
X2 is an rd2
and D equals D1 plus D2 okay so this is
just a nice way of partitioning this is
because we're dealing with something
that's linear and we can have this kind
of block structure okay we can also do
this for matrices and that will allow us
to State some theorems so just a little
bit more concisely
Sigma 1 1
Sigma 2 1
Sigma so this should be two one sorry
of course
one two
Sigma 2 2. maybe I
okay I hope I didn't do something else
right so this is D1 this is D2
this is uh going to be D1 and this is
going to be D2
all right
and sigma i j
if I've done my job
should be oh it's going to be R that's
why I did it the backward side that
makes more sense
so my day is going to be D
uh J or hold on
let me actually change the numbering
just to make it consistent with the
notes sorry
this doesn't really matter conceptually
but just to explain it
okay
one two all right
so the point is is I can I can Factor
this in some way and it makes sense to
multiply a matrix in an obvious way if
it's compatible with the block so like
if I multiply this Matrix here x times
Sigma I can write it in terms of these
blocks hopefully that's clear right it
would be Sigma 1 1 times Sigma 2 1 and
that would be what I would want to put
there okay all right this is a very
widely used notation and it's going to
let us state two facts about gaussians
that are really helpful
if you're not familiar with it just take
a look at it and see so first one is the
marginalization identity for gaussians
X2
px1 X2
okay for gaussians this has a nice form
this is not true in general this is why
we love gaussian so much really or that
it has this really nice form
P X1 is going to be equal to
a normal is going to be distributed like
a normal
mu 1 1
Sigma 1 1.
okay this is called marginalization
it basically means I can grab the mean
that I want to grab and the covariance I
want to grab when I marginalize them out
and this is because gaussians have this
nice property
about you know being independent in
these directions
okay
this is a much nastier statement in fact
two which we will use
px1 conditioned on x2 is also gaussian
pretty remarkable if I'm going to be
honest like not a lot of distributions
are closed in this way what I mean is
close if I take if I do an operation
like conditioning do I get back the same
distribution that's actually pretty
unlikely but gaussians it happens and so
again it makes some of our calculations
easier
it's marginalization
this is conditioning okay and so what
are these two values
this is going to be equal to Mu 1 plus
Sigma 1 2
Sigma 2 2 and I'll put up notes and you
can look and see the the notes do this
X2 minus mu this looks super mysterious
it's actually not but it's not probably
worth going into too much detail if you
remember your Matrix inversion lemas if
you don't again don't worry these are
not super conceptual like important
details it's just how this works you can
go through and I can gladly upload a
proof for you if that makes you feel
more solidly grounded if not you can
just use this
okay and these are these formulas when I
say it's not conceptually important you
may think that's a cop-out maybe it is
but really the reason is it doesn't
matter to me because there's only one
way these formulas make sense the types
all work out you have d1s and d2s and
you're multiplying them in the right way
otherwise the formula is wrong okay
okay so this is the Matrix inversion
limit if that helps you great
I'm happy to prove it the thing that I
care that you take away is that we have
these formulas and we can use them later
so when we do a conditioning step we can
use them okay when we do a
marginalization we can use them
okay and this is I I realize this is
like impossible to appreciate at this
moment probably but it's
um It's relatively rare that we can go
from distribution condition on it and
get back a distribution right that we
have the same what are called sufficient
statistics but it happens here just
don't expect that General please
dependencies between not just within
different data like between datas
the features of the data uh so I
wouldn't look at it through that lens
these are mathematical facts about
gaussian distributions these have
nothing to do with data per se this is
just true about any kind of wild
gaussian that you would want to meet and
so you would use it that way we are
going to you we are going to show in one
second that that crazy model I just
showed you can be written in kind of a
nice way
uh using these things so how do we use
it so remember we have two variables
n
Sigma
right
all right and this is since
Epsilon of Z the expected value of Z is
equal to zero
and the expected value of x equals mu
now we don't know Sigma yet we just say
there's a covariance out there we're
going to derive what it is in one second
but the point is is that whole Factor
model basically boils down to some
gigantic gaussian and that's going to be
really helpful to us the problem is
like this form like this is going to be
data
this is going to be hidden and so we're
going to have to deal with
marginalization and conditionaling and
all the rest of it to be able to recover
it but the point is we can write that
model super compactly now I think if I
wrote that first probably you wouldn't
be super happy
maybe you'd be really happy I don't know
maybe you're happy folks
which line
so
and again you can type check these
things just make sure it makes sense
it's got to be a d by D map
or an N by D map for everything to make
sense and all the types checked out if
there are typos which I'm sure there are
okay so let's try and now our job is to
try and figure out what is Sigma and by
the way this is kind of remarkable like
we went through this pretty elaborate
discussion
about
various different models you know how
the model worked
and lo and behold
it's just some nice gaussian what is the
so this is a so it's because it's block
one one is the outer product of Z with
itself
well what's the outer product of Z with
itself it's just the identity why is it
the identity because that's the way we
sampled remember we sampled in a low
space this is using this fact oops
is using this fact
right so e expected value of ZZ
transpose that is exactly I
what is Sigma 1 2
well it's going to be the expected value
of Z times x minus mu
transpose
what is that actually equal
well that's going to be the expected
value of
z z
transpose right so x minus mu equals
what it equals Lambda Z Plus Epsilon
right that's just the model I just
subtracted off the MU on both sides
so it's going to be z z transpose Lambda
transpose
plus e
Z
Epsilon transpose
now these two things are independent
oops Z and Epsilon are independent so
boom
this goes to zero
this we just concluded
I'm sorry this we just concluded was the
identity
so this equals Lambda transpose
and sigma 2 1 oops I'll write in a
proper in the other color
Sigma T1
equals
Sigma 1 2 transpose because that's it's
a covariance matrix positive sum it's
symmetric okay
the last one
or you can just compute it take my word
for it but you don't have to take my
word for it
is this one x minus mu
x minus mu transpose
we just use this formula again
that's going to be the expected value
of Lambda Z Plus Epsilon
Lambda Z Plus Epsilon transpose we have
some multiplications to do
we know that all the cross terms with
Epsilon are going to cancel out
so this is going to look like
and I this will maybe look mysterious so
I'm going to maybe I'll go a little bit
slower here
um then I wrote my notes Epsilon Epsilon
transpose okay so why notice you're
going to have an Epsilon times this term
and the transpose but the expected value
of Epsilon is zero so those term cross
term is going to cancel the only one
that's going to remain are this one and
this one where the epsilons are
multiplied by itself so both cross terms
Fall Away
what does this equal well we just saw
this is a random variable this is a
deterministic parameter of the problem
this is going to be Lambda Lambda
transpose and this is going to be plus
the Phi why did that happen
this Phi
is the model sorry for the scrolling so
please avert your eyes if it makes you
nauseous it's this character
sound good
so let's write the whole model in
summary
and again you can check the types on
this thing make sure I didn't make some
silly mistake
okay
and we're good
so now it's in this nice gaussian form
and oh my gosh I claim you already know
how to solve this
e-step what is Qi of Z I won't go
through the holy M algorithm remember is
p z of I
given x i
and Theta
what do we use here
we only have two rules
yeah use the conditional that's all we
got use the conditional
m-step
well it's just it's a normal
distribution where we filled in the x's
and we're marginalizing out after seeing
the X's that are in there or
conditionally on the Z's we have close
forms
you already know how to do this
okay
so what is the summary here
we saw here this factor analysis
structure that allowed us to have a
lower dimensional space
how this elaborate kind of sampling and
moving around pretty wild uh set of
generative models
and it basically boiled down to a
one-liner to shoe and Horn into the EM
algorithm
we had to use some fancy you know tricks
with how you deal with normal
distributions
if you didn't use those fancy tricks for
normal distributions you would have to
do some empirical extra work right you'd
have to understand if I had a
distribution that looked like blonde I
wanted to marginalize or condition it
what would I do on top
yeah please
oh because once we have this these are
just like so think about what happens
once we have the estimates for the Z
then it's just conditioning on the Z's
and removing them and we know how to
estimate the parameters of a like this
becomes just a standard oops where's the
formula sorry for the Mad scrolling
the crazy scrolling is here
once you know Z you have a guess of Z
then this is just fitting a gaussian
with a unknown mu and sigma
and you need to figure out what the
sigma is that you're fitting but you
know how to do that you so I guess this
is something we've done you know maybe K
lectures in a row and it is I agree with
you like it is abstract and weird that
that falls out and I want to say it in
that abstract and weird way so that
you're not afraid of it because you're
gonna you know if you want to go into
these things you want to use these
things like it'll look very strange but
once you get in that form it's just kind
of a plug and chug kind of mentality to
to get all the results from things you
already know derivatives you already
know how to compute
go ahead
um
oh so that's just the definition of
covariance so because I know that just
the distributions I want to compute what
Sigma must be and I'm just trying to
tell you the reason I wrote it that way
is to tell you there's nothing else
going on in the model I'm just Computing
the expectations I know the covariance
of the individual objects and that is
telling me like
that I can write it in this form
all right
let's use 20 minutes to do PCA and we
should be in good shape
PCA all right so PCA
I'm going to draw this little diagram
to explain where we are
principal component analysis so we
looked I want to fill out this table you
say why do you want to fill out the
tables I don't know just how I do it I
like that it fits
also you should know it it's an
important algorithm it'd be weird if we
didn't teach it
although probably a bunch of you have
seen it before if not don't worry about
it
so one of the things that's inside
machine learning which is really kind of
interesting historically I won't bore
you too much with like you know the
various tribes of like machine learning
theory and how how we got where we got
and who fought with whom at which
conference although it's kind of funny
because it like
so bizarre but
there are kind of two schools of thought
of doing machine learning and uh you
know at a kind of a broad level there's
kind of the Bayesian school of thought
which is everything should be written
down as a probability distribution
maximum likelihood we write these priors
we use conjugate priors we kind of crank
through the model and we have this
forward story and there was kind of
another Camp that's like kind of more
the frequentest style world just from
the stat side that was like we don't
want to use probabilities we just want
to have these kind of nice estimates
they also like maximum likelihood they
also like Bayes rule but they differ in
some ways of like how you approach
modeling and what a valid model is like
how you know to trust a model okay it
doesn't matter at all the point is
almost everything in machine learning
has kind of these two different
approaches and I'll say at one point in
my career early in my career I built a
system which was like very much in the
probabilistic camp and then became kind
of disillusioned with it and moved to
doing something else
um but there are merits to both
approaches PCA is what we're going to
talk about so that's just historical
context I just want you to know there
are many ways to Model A lot of these
different problems and we're going to
talk about this one here and I want you
to explicitly contrast it with factor
analysis which is the probabilistic
version kind of a PCA in the same way
k-means and GMM have a parallel
structure okay you saw k-means we did
GMM they had a nice kind of rhythm of
how they were solving the underlying
problem so it was nice to put them
together these don't have that nice
Rhythm but they they have something else
that is nice to see all right so let's
see PCA
thank you
okay so we're going to be given pairs
here this is kind of a weird example but
it's something that makes uh hopefully
the main point clear
okay so imagine someone gave us
a data set and this data set had a bunch
of cars on it and the cars are going to
be rated on
like kind of Highway
miles per gallon
and City okay and these are gas cars
these aren't uh electric cars
okay so they're kind of scattered all
over this
okay and I actually went and got the
real data it's not that interesting but
you know there's a couple that are
substantially better substantially worse
than the line okay now imagine these
cluster up here just to give you kind of
complete the story these are maybe
hybrids oops
these are hybrids
maybe these are SUVs
they have bad gas mileage or trucks or
something
and these are economy cars I don't know
okay
clear what the visualization is saying
so we ask a question which at first
seems kind of strange but you know it's
a question we could ask nonetheless
what does it mean for a car to have a
good miles per gallon now some cars are
going to be better on the city some cars
are going to be better on the highway we
can kind of on like a single direction
or a single kind of way that says what
is the component of principal variation
right for good miles per gallon and
that's kind of what we're trying to ask
and by the way PCA is typically employed
in these settings when we don't know too
much about our data we want to visualize
it in some way or get some understanding
right modern methods kind of incorporate
a lot of its ideas so you don't need to
run it usually as a standalone ahead of
time anymore like they worry about these
features and things but it focuses on
one thing I really think is great so how
do we deal with this all right so the
first thing we do is we take our data
and the PCA worldview
and we Center it okay
okay now what does it mean Center
we compute mu
which is equal to 1 by n some I equals 1
to n
x i and this is and then we subtract mu
from every Point here
to get it to get the center of the data
set at zero okay should be balanced in
all ways
this is just to make sure that the scale
the raw numbers don't matter because
we're going to talk about geometry and
also we're going to use some ideas from
linear algebra and linear algebra likes
things that go through the origin right
we like linear Maps linear maps go
through the origin so we want to like
the origin has a special role of linear
algebra this is still a highway
okay now if I look and I just eyeball it
roughly speaking it feels like the
component of variation is something like
this
right and what I mean is if I look along
that direction that tells me like the
more I go along that the better the
highway model is or some variation
that's that's around that but that's
like good miles per gallon and Below as
you go those are like slightly worse so
along this this line
is kind of the principal direction of
variation it doesn't capture everything
right like there's this character way
over here there's some character way
over here this is an automated way of
kind of denoising those data sets and
other things that I'm looking at and so
what we'll talk about is this direction
mu1 which will typically be a unit
Vector is a component of principal
variation
okay this is very intuitive I'll Define
it formally in a second you want
and if I look I can still describe all
my points this is just linear algebra by
something that's orthogonal and I'll
call it U2
okay now I'll construct
U1 and U2 because I only care about
their directions to be unit vectors
okay and so you can kind of think about
U1 as how good is the mile per gallon
and U2 is kind of explaining its first
variance right like it's the first if
you thought about it it's probabilistic
it would be like the first direction
that they vary a core varies and then
like what's that second order effect you
can imagine doing this in higher
dimensions
all right
formally one second we can write
x i equals Alpha
i1 times mu1 plus Alpha I 2 mu2
and these are scalars
okay this is just linear algebra please
go ahead you had a question
yeah we're just eyeballing it for now
I'm saying that like it looks roughly
correct we're gonna find how do we find
that line in just two minutes five
minutes
so let me once we write the definition
let's come back and you and then
hopefully your intuition and my
intuition will be a little bit closer
right
but yeah that's a great question you're
exactly you're thinking exactly the
right way why is that the right line why
is this Maniac drawing that line right
now the thing is is we may only decide
by the way to use this as dimensionality
we may only keep this component
okay because it explains more variation
and that's going to be how we Define it
variation
okay so what we want to do here just so
you're clear so here I drew it from two
to one just as I was drawing before but
think about if I had thousands of
Dimensions you can't possibly visualize
thousands of dimensions
it's really tough
and I want to get it down to say you
know two or three
or five or ten
right I want to find those principal
variants okay and so PCA also functions
as a dimensionality reduction method
okay so here we show just a two
dimensional plot but imagine I gave you
the cars have thousands of numbers and
you want to get a very succinct
description of them as just five numbers
or I gave you a 10 000 sensors as we
were talking about before and you wanted
to figure out give me three numbers
which really describe every different
individual sensor and its variation from
that number it's very similar to factor
analysis right like it's looking for
that low dimensional Subspace that you
want in fact it is formerly a low
dimensional Subspace it is a dimension
of Dimension two or three or k
underneath the covers and we'll come to
that in one second okay so at this point
this is intuition you should have more
questions and answers let me State the
algorithm that we're going to do the
pre-processing that we're going to do
and then you'll see why some of these
variation things are please go ahead
proposing is that
yes
I'm saying great question so imagine I
gave you this X1 to xn that live in some
high dimensional space d
then what I'm going to try and do is
find a smaller number of directions but
those directions are not necessarily
aligned with the axis which means
they're not like component five seven or
nine there's some mixture of all of them
and so U is not aligned with an access
right it's some mixture of of the of the
highway Direction in the city Direction
and I'm going to find that direction and
then I'm going to say that's the
direction that the data set varies most
in there's the most spread in so I want
to keep where you are on that line I'll
project you on that line then maybe the
second the third and that's going to be
like a third kind of you know a three
numbers that best capture you in the
data set if you're an individual data
point
uh not noise but I'm just not modeling
them yeah
what's up what's up
um quadratic relationship
s
yeah how does It capture their Direction
uh wonderful question so we'll come back
to that in a little bit effectively what
we're going to do is we're going to
capture some variation that's there so
there may actually be some of these
hidden correlations that are underneath
the covers and we we won't model them
well or we may only model them well in
different pieces of data there are
methods if I know that there's a
non-linear relationship between a lot of
the different elements of data that like
I can I can capture here we're assuming
there exists a linear Subspace and
that's a fairly robust assumption so
people do use more Advanced Techniques
like TC and umap which do have actually
the assumption that there's some very
compressible non-linear map that
explains what's going on but PCA is kind
of the the first and the in the cleanest
to describe yeah
awesome question
okay so we Center the data by the way
just I'm going to review this one second
I'm just trying to write so we can get
through this uh mu we know what it is 1
by n some I
want to n x i
okay we need may need to rescale the
components
why is this
well what if one component was miles per
gallon and another was feet per gallon
they're just different by a factor of
five thousand there'd be a lot of
variation in the feet per gallon right
not the miles per gallon the numbers
would be different so not only do we
want to like Center them and get them
both centered around zero we want to
rescale them so that they have exactly
uh kind of the same width and what we'll
do is we'll just divide
by the variance by the sample variance
right in that direction so that all the
numbers are kind of like roughly
normally distributed you should you
should think okay so we're going to
assume that the data are pre-processed
if you actually do this method you
should do the pre-processing so let's
see PCA as an optimization problem
all right
oops
Monkey Business
I'll live with it
okay all right so
here's what we're trying to solve and
this will get back to some of the
questions that were asked about hey what
do we what do we uh why do we think this
is a direction principal Direction okay
we need it we need a little bit of of uh
of math before we can make that precise
X okay
so what we want to solve right what we
have is we have some direction U1 we
have some other direction mu 2 which is
orthogonal this is mu1 we have some
direction mu 2 which is orthogonal
we have
these are unit vectors
UI equals one
so unit vectors and they're orthogonal
UI dot mu J equals zero or equal sorry
equals Delta i j
orthogonal
okay so how do you find the closest
point
on this line to X
well this line just to be clear could be
parameterized as T times U1 for T
element of r
right it's just a line one dimensional
line and so to find Alpha
how do we find Alpha above
closest point
that's the following expression alpha 1
equals the argument
over Alpha
of x minus Alpha mu1 Norm Square
okay
right so hopefully this makes sense if I
want to find the closest point
intuitively it should be on the line
that's orthogonal here it's not a very
great drawing but that's where it should
be it should be projected onto this line
and we can minimize over the whole line
by minimizing over Alpha
we do the standard thing here
we compute the derivatives we multiply
it out
right so this is equivalent to when we
multiply it out ARG min
x square plus Alpha Square Times mu 1
square minus 2 Alpha mu 1 dot X
this is argument over Alpha
this doesn't change this is a function
of the input
this is one
so when we go to compute the derivative
what do we get
we get 2 Alpha
minus
two
um
UI 1 dot X
okay or
said more simply Alpha equals zero right
this is the gradient with respect to
Alpha so Alpha equals
mu 1.x okay this is saying the dot
product in this direction
tells us exactly the closest point
this is just differentiating this
expression with respect to Alpha
okay
all right now
you can generalize this to any set of
directions
orthogonal directions so if I have mu 1
to Mu K element of Rd
and X element of Rd
how do I find the closest point to the
Subspace span by mu I
here we're going to use the fact that mu
I J equals T Delta i j
well it's going to be the following
argument
Alpha One Alpha k
x minus sum k equals 1 to n or sorry J
equals 1 to K
Alpha j u k
now expand that out again exactly as we
did before
and you'll see that Alpha I is equal to
Mu I or u i dotted into X this is the
inner product if you like
okay
we call
this quantity X
minus sum Alpha J
u j sorry this is u j u j Square
okay okay the residual
okay so we have everything we need
rushing a little bit here but so the
point I want to make is if you have a
Subspace and you want to find the
closest point in that Subspace to X
that's the same as minimizing over all
the possible directions in the Subspace
this distance squared distance squared
makes the computation easier
then Alpha I if you solve it is going to
break apart and the reason it's going to
break apart is when you multiply it
apart like this you're going to get
products of mu I and u j they will all
go away
so all you'll be left with is a bunch
of the alpha eyes and Alpha J's that are
multiplied in exactly the same way as
the 1D case you should check that and
this is you know if if you're Rusty on
this is from your linear algebra class
and I'm super happy to write it out in
more detail if that confuses you but for
now hopefully we can we can just move
through this okay this thing here is the
residual that says how close am I what's
my distance from X to the Subspace
and that's going to feature prominently
in what we do next
please
so so what we're going to try and do is
we're going to try and find a low
dimensional Subspace and I'll describe
how we're going to do it next and PCA
when we're talking about what's the
principal component of variation we're
going to search across all the
directions when we're looking for the
principal component we're going to say
which one of them has this for example
there are two ways we can find PCA but
has the smallest residual
or
will be equivalent maximizes the amount
of alpha the amount we projected onto
the subset okay so there are two ways
you can do this so we can find PCA
by
one
maximizing
the projected amount that means trying
to make alpha as large as possible
right so if you give me a Subspace which
is a section of of vectors I can compute
the alphas by solving this problem
I want to compute something so that a
Direction so that for almost all the
data points my Alphas are as large as
possible
so getting back to the earlier question
about why did I say that direction was
the principal component of variation is
because if I put it in that direction I
was kind of explaining the most and the
residuals the errors were small
dually these residuals for every Point
are as small as possible and we're going
to minimize those in one second yeah go
ahead
we did
uh awesome question no not necessarily
right because for example think about
even if we we normalized it there may be
One Direction that explains for example
the temperature how far it is away from
the heat Source back to my thousand
temperature sensor example and there's
one direction that explains that but
there still could be variations in other
directions that are not captured by any
other process and so they would be
orthogonal to that so it's not necessary
that the
um that the all even though all the
directions on average are normalized
that for any particular Point like if
there's a correlation wouldn't would be
the same
the Lord
so all the access are are put into the
same scale by taking each individual
component and Computing at sample
variance yeah multiplying by a diagonal
matrix please
so here alpha alpha is is basically T so
it tells you how far along the line
you're going to go so Alpha is
constrained to live on the line so when
we minimize over Alpha we're minimizing
its coordinate along the line and that's
well defined right there's only there's
a closest point here right we know that
kind of intuitively from you know
undergrad whatever whatever geometry we
took right like that there's a closest
point but this proves it right
awesome
cool please
yeah so it's either you wanna you wanna
capture as much of your data as possible
and in a linear case it's either you
want to you want to capture as much as
possible or minimize the residual or
turn out to be equivalent because here
if you look at it because these are unit
vectors
making Alpha J is bigger like if you if
I had two sets of U's you know
you and I'm comparing them if the alphas
are bigger for this one on average than
them for this one then that says that
they capture more of my data right
because they're a projection the alphas
are defined by the use
yep
all right
so let's find the component principle
component of direction right so what
this boils down to I'll just do one of
the methods
the maximization one you have to do the
other one in your homework by the way so
I'm
just one reason to pay attention
is this
it says look over all the directions
sorry you
okay so it says look over all the
directions that are out there
dot them into the data set this is Alpha
right this is the alpha we were just
talking about and try and maximize the
one that captures most of it so if you
imagine me sweeping that line across the
earlier data set where we're looking
here
right here and I'm sweeping that line
here here here my or all from the origin
sorry go ahead here here clearly this
captures much more the alphas are much
larger than they are here
just take the dot products
right because it's just projecting onto
a relatively narrow band it doesn't
capture as much spread
I want more spread right it's
quadratically more spread
okay
so how do we solve this question
here
well
we need a couple of facts okay maybe we
will
pick this up in a little bit
yeah I think that's probably best so let
me ask me any questions about particular
spot we'll come back about how to solve
this kind of equation and
any other questions about this piece
yeah
like
so what is by maximizing projected
subscripts you're just trying to ensure
that whatever you want is we choose
um
[Music]
exactly right they capture the most a
day so think about when we were going
back to our earlier example this isn't
this is important we were going to have
U1 and U2 that was like our basis right
that's formally what's called we want to
capture so it turns out that the the
squares of alpha 1 and Alpha 2 sum to
the square of X I's components like
their Norms are the same
okay
that's just a mathematical fact because
these are these are this is what a basis
is so so the the point is is we want to
capture of these two we're going to
throw away Alpha two if we only are
allowed to compute one component so we
want the the U that we select to be the
one that for most of the data capture
some relevant information right like if
we found something like this direction
is mostly orthogonal to where the line
that the data lives on so almost
everybody's going to have like a
projection that's really small like the
data when I project onto the line is
going to be clustered really really
tightly together whereas if I cluster if
I project onto this line it's still
going to be nice and spread out
and this mathematically just says that
it corresponds to either making sure
that the alphas overall are very close
to the X's so they're larger on average
or that the amount that I lose this is
the residual is the amount that I lose
from the other directions is
equivalently small and then and for for
PCA and euclidean space this is the case
not relevant for this class but there
are other dimensions there are other
kinds of geometries where that's not
true this happens to be true for
eucliding geometry
if you decide to take nonuclear in
Geometry it's a great course
oh x i oh let me just write it again
nice catch
eyes don't show up very well with this
pen in my handwriting
which is Criminal since we use them so
frequently just assume it's an eye but
that's all it goes on right so we're
thinking about what this equation is
saying with this optimization is saying
it says pick over all the U's that are
there
we're normalizing come back to why we
normalize it doesn't really matter too
much but what we want to do is explain
as much of the data as we can
awesome
so next time we will cover a little bit
of eigenvalues and how we solve this
this is a this is an eigenvalue problem
and we'll cover the cocktail problem as
well and you saw a little bit of of PCA
thanks so much for your time and
attention talk soon